so much is happening how much we
shouldn't have listened through spite of
it or maybe because of it
so what we do the first half of season
seven was very much about these
characters and the audience finding
their way forward from an incredible
trauma it was really value just assume
you are awake of it and how you keep
yourself together and Kenny we were
something good okay so explain recover
phone everybody is broken we have to
agree we're in mourning at the same time
we have to pick up the pieces and figure
out how we move forward let me put this
to all of you as clearly as I can I'm
not in charge anymore
you did the worst 15 Rick just so
defeated oh it makes Rick believe that
the only way forward is compliant it's
not how the group is built to actually
cater to this type of oppressive tyranny
it begins with a man being obedient and
going out of his way and risking his
life for negan in order to preserve life
in Alexandria but throughout there are
six sessions of moments that change his
mind and makes him realize that this is
an untenable situation
by the end we see that all of these
characters that have been in different
places have wound up on the same page
the promise of the future is that okay
they weren't ready they weren't in a
place to fight they are now there is
this moment of optimism one of the rare
rare moments in this front aid that you
know we're rebuilding and we're together
again or at least it's the beginning of
the resistance
did you see that hope that we just maybe
might can an interesting journey the
first half of seven and it's only gonna
get more crazy they're seeing people now
in a whole new place of really
strategizing but really against
magnificent on there are some very
practical
don't have the weapons they don't have
the manpower they've got the will now
it's up to us to go out and find other
communities who are willing to fight and
take them down game - it came to ask you
to join us fighting the state fighting
for freedom for all in the second half
of season seven there's a storm coming
and it is a very different fight it
can't be won with just physical force
what we're building toward the end no
seven is Rick trying to reimagine find
himself again
still there with a big smile on his face
wait so you know we're getting to the
breaking point
hey youtubers is Charlie walking dead is
back in a couple weeks so let's break
this down episode 9 is actually going to
air the weekend after the Super Bowl
they're not going to try and beat the
Super Bowl
usually the Walking Dead ratings
actually beat Sunday Night Football on a
regular basis but in the United States
it's just the most-watched thing ever
tonight to the heirs it's kind of like
watching the world cup of soccer like
everybody is watching it tonight it airs
so it is foolish to try and air some
other big program against it so there
will be a new Walking Dead giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video you can kind of see from the
footage that this is all march to war
stuff Rick Grimes the survivors meeting
with the people at Hilltop Jesus
deciding to go meet the kingdom and
start to assemble their team because
everybody has something that the other
group needs they need weapons that's
where the kingdom comes in but so far
Ezekiel has had this policy where he
just tried to appease the Savior's but
now they're trying to get him to step up
they had that secret plan during the
first half of the season to feed them
the tainted meat so they've already been
trying to take down the Savior's at a
very slow rate it's a bit of a long con
because they haven't really shown you
the scope of the Savior's they sort of
tease that idea
like when Michonne is taking that woman
to go kill negan she points down the
hill to all the people that are
assembled and says you might make it
past a couple of them but there are just
so many their numbers are so great that
you have zero chances so mission number
one in the next couple of episodes is
assembling Walking Dead Voltron so that
Rick Grimes can take down negan but even
beyond that we got a tease for these
Garbage Pail Kids so like they say that
there's going to be more groups coming
on we already know about the really big
ones but there are even more beyond that
like that's how big the Savior's are
they need as many as they can get even
the combined forces of the SafeZone
hilltop the kingdom in Oceanside who
also have a lot of weapons so the
kingdom has armor weapons but so does
oceanside too so they're really
important even all of them together
won't be enough to defeat negan in the
Savior's that's how big they are they
although satellite stations so that's
where the secret card comes in from the
Terra episode did everybody hated so
much so there are important things that
they bury in the filler episodes and
everybody complained about that they're
like why are we getting a terror episode
but at least they snuck something in
that they'll pay off later there are a
couple rumors about Chandler Riggs
status on the show because he's going to
school so I'll address that at the end
of this - so just explains a key card
theory the best theory that I've seen so
far is that because the Savior's use
those satellite radio stations to
communicate that's where their real
strength is is they have like a couple
people in satellite stations all over
the place so that they can marshal their
forces in an instant when they need to
so in order to access this vast
communication network you need one of
those key cards to get into the building
so that's probably what this is so when
it seemed like Heath had bailed
what really probably happened is that he
was taken by the Savior's but that key
card was left behind so that will be the
key that they need to start dismantling
their communication network and then
they can start picking them off because
a group like negan's you can't just take
them head-on they would totally lose you
have to flank them take their advantages
away and that gets into their
communication network so you guys can
let me know how do you think that
they're going to start fighting the
Savior's they've got the tainted meat so
far they've got the weapons from
Oceanside and now once they figure out
what they have they can start picking
them off one at a time like the little
pockets of the Savior's before they go
full-on to negan's home base so what
about Chandler Briggs there's rumors
that what's going to happen at the end
of season seven before season 8 is that
there'll be a time jump and it'll
explain how Carl is getting so big so
fast so that doesn't mean that he's
absolutely done with this show but he
will be on it a little bit less that's
just what I'm expecting between classes
so he'll come back on they can do
flashbacks so that doesn't mean that
they're going to kill Carl off he's
still going to be walking dead family
he'll still come back on but it won't be
as much as he's been on in the past
although to be honest there haven't been
that many Carl episodes to begin with so
it's not like
are going to be changing things a lot it
just that you will notice him much less
but it all depends on what he does with
his season 8 contract he just his
seventh season contract was up so
anything could change he could change
his mind and just film all of his stuff
around his school schedule so he'll
still be doing Walking Dead stuff no
matter what it's just a question of how
much Walking Dead stuff but what's going
to happen this weekend because there's
not going to be an episode they will
probably drop some new footage so I'll
do a new video in the next couple of
days but later tonight I have some new
Marvel guardians of the galaxy there's
new Star Wars Episode 8 new Game of
Thrones and all the postings so I'll try
to get that stuff out as fast as
possible what you guys wait for that's a
post you can click here for all my
Walking Dead Season 7 videos and you can
click here to learn about the zombie
flash on legends of tomorrow thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you in the next video